it's quite a thing right you get done
with your video you upload it and you're
like all right the video's done
bring on the weekend
and now we're here why because in my
thor 11 thunder spoiler video some of
the nitpicks some of the things i said
it was incorrect information this cannot
stand also i feel like disney's gonna
demonetize this better to have the vader
face looking at you than the star wars
loco gotta think about this [ __ ] on this
platform so i dressed up in my sunday
best robe t-shirt
oh that's it and now i must correct the
false information i gave actually i did
this all wrong i started out completely
wrong i'm a youtuber for [ __ ] sake
should know this videos like this need
to start out really somber with a sigh
hi also spoiler warning spoiler warning
is warranted this video is me talking
about things i said in my thor 11
thunder spoiler review i'm really
excited to make this video i don't know
why i just seems fun so let's kick back
relax have a fun time a good
conversation just kind of weirdly well
it is a conversation i was gonna say
it's a one-sided conversation because
i'm just talking at you but i am
responding to comments so it's kind of a
conversation anyhow false [ __ ]
slinging number one oh god why is the
font so small i'm just gonna put an
overlay on the screen so you don't see
me reading it like this like an idiot
but in my video one of the things i said
was that the sword was corrupting gore
and i was like why can't you just have
bad guys be bad guys someone said i
think the sword was corrupting gore in
the physical sense but his actions and
motivations were all his own which funny
enough that that conversation is in the
comment section there are people who see
it how i saw it they're like ah that's
how i saw it and other people who were
like no the sword wasn't corrupting him
it was just making him physically messed
up but his actions were still his own
and it might very well be true this is
one of the ones i'm like i i still see
it how i said it but gore does feel like
a completely different character you
know at first he's like gore who looks
like quan chi's really cool brother then
he goes to looking like christopher
walken in sleepy hollow had a kid with a
sith lord nightmare and he acts a little
different you know at first he just kind
of acts like a dude who's in pain then
he goes out of his way and even takes
pleasure in terrifying the living [ __ ]
out of children he just he acts
different then when the store is
destroyed he goes back to looking like
quan chi's cool brother and he just acts
more chill i mean granted basically all
he does is he cries when his
his wish daughter comes out of the
wishing well maybe they should have done
that maybe they should have still had
gore look like the beast under your bed
in your closet in your head but still
had him cry when his daughter showed up
so people could be like oh he's like the
same person maybe if he got more time
with gore the god butcher and actually
showed him kill gods and had some
dialogue there maybe maybe it'd be more
clear but he never feels that way for me
when he has the sword he feels like a
different character than when he doesn't
have the sword next thing was when i was
like why didn't thor just make a lot of
wishes when he got to the wishing well i
feel like i remember someone saying that
only the first person to reach eternity
can make one wish that's why thor didn't
do anything at the end lol
props to the lol touch i like that i'm
gonna be honest with you
i don't remember that at all which is
probably the biggest mistake i made in
that entire video talking about thor 11
thunder at all is i got the rating wrong
apparently it's just one of those not
gonna remember it in t minus one day
kind of jobs
because
apparently i didn't but okay it was
pretty cut and dry all right this dude
with a time stamp which is very thorough
he didn't say kids who believed in gods
had the power of thor for a limited time
which would have been fine blah blah
blah he said the kids who were worthy
because their peer of heart could borrow
the power of thor for a limited time
well my belief statement wasn't that
they believed in thor's that they
believed that they were worthy that's
the belief regardless okay so if the
kids are worthy i knew there was
something left on the table with that
thing that thor did and giving kids
powers where i was like
not all the kids would get that like
there's a possibility that a kid would
not yeah kids oh they're innocent
they're wonderful we all love to believe
that but i've seen the good sun and it's
just not true i'm just saying there had
to have been a possibility that at least
one kid would be there and not get the
powers just turtle in the corner kind of
like that low-level person who groups up
for a raid and the people doing the
heavy lifting are like oh okay he's
using us to power level okay enjoy the
xp we're gonna get to work or they just
boot them feel like at least one kid
there would be like i don't have any
sparkly fingers what the f i'm what the
i haven't moved on to humans yet they're
just animals i just wanted to see what
it feels like to have the light leave
their eyes i guess i'm not making my
case any better
i'm just saying about thor sharing his
powers with the kids i think it's thanks
to zeus's thunder thingy i like that
that's the official term now as far as
i'm concerned i was like well how did he
give his power to kids and couldn't he
have done that in wakanda when they were
gonna fight thanos turns out plot twist
that isn't really a plot twist it to his
credit is color-coded so okay it gives
them the powers of zeus not thor so it
couldn't have happened before this movie
because now he has the lightning bolt
the zoo the zoo lightning bolt thingy
because they had the yellow lightning
which is zeus lightning they didn't have
the white lightning which is thor
lightning so those are basically the big
three anyway which was like why didn't
he make a wish when he got to the
wishing well was the sword corrupting
gore and how did he give lightning
powers to the little kids and why didn't
he do that before this movie to other
characters he might have run into so
there we go actually we have a little
bit of time there are more comments that
were just fun maybe we'll hit those up
because why not we're here someone said
at 11 29 i tested the hypothesis with
jack and coke in the theater and let me
tell you it didn't help at all if
anything it just kept me laughing at how
basic and not well thought out the film
was that would be me saying hey i said a
good time if you're drunk let's test the
hypothesis well i'm not going to but you
can apparently someone did and it
doesn't work it's okay i'm switching the
rating t-minus there you go this is
actually a pretty good one i mean it's
not it's one of those things where when
you make new stories in ever expanding
universe among different writers and
directors you run into situations like
this i wonder why did thanos spend all
those years to find the stones or
fighting avengers when he could just try
to find the center of the universe and
make a wish and this is the real
explanation right here you can have your
canonical explanation your story-based
explanation but in the end it comes down
to this no one creating these movies
when thanos was the focal point knew
this thing even existed i love the fact
that there are replies there's a
conversation happening over stormbreaker
was the key to finding this thing so
yeah i'm gonna go ahead and go with
because they didn't know this thing was
a thing right in the end the
responsibility to write the wrongs of
the misinformation i gave in a world
where pop culture is the politics of the
21st century is done because if that is
in fact the case being wrong about pop
culture essentially is now categorized
under misinformation i don't want my
channel to disappear it's not really why
no i'm just being a snarky dick point is
like one wrong thing in a video i always
just kind of accept the fact that that's
going to happen but when it got to about
three it was like okay
i wanna make a video to show other
youtube content creators out there that
it's okay to be wrong and it's okay to
address the things that you were wrong
about especially if you can milk another
video out of it baby
it's not the only reason
but no this video is fun because it's a
little different and why not also very
important question and i really do mean
this
where the [ __ ] did all the morbius memes
come from
[Music]
you